these bioreactors may soon be churning
out
cell-based meat for american diners
this is said to be the world's first
industrial
cell-based meat facility the meat here
doesn't come from slaughtering animals
instead it's grown from animal cells in
bioreactors
the cultured meat industry is at a stage
of transitioning from lab to
factory in a way it's proven that
technology can work
and in fact startups can produce that
type of meat
and now the challenge is to actually
produce this meat in large quantities
future meat technologies will produce up
to 1100 pounds of meat a day in this
plant
it's raised 43 million dollars from
investors
including meat giant tyson foods
the company from the start set
a target to actually produce
commercially viable
culture needs and therefore has really
focused on
bringing the production costs down and
finding way to scale up production
but it's not an easy road ahead for the
industry
one thing is scaling up production
bringing the costs down getting prices
to be
as close to conventional meat as
possible
in order to convince consumers
to switch consumers need to actually
embrace the product they need to trust
it
so winning over consumers and as well as
regulators
will be key if consumers take to these
products the market could reach 25
billion dollars by 2030 that's according
to mckinsey and co
at the moment cultured meat is only
allowed to be sold in singapore
but future meat technologies is in talks
with u.s regulators to start offering
its products
in restaurants by the end of next year
so would you try it